now in China business owners say they
are struggling to make ends meet despite
the government's loosening of strict
coronavirus measures anger over the
restrictions has now given way to worry
about how to cope with the infection and
that means many people are still staying
indoors
Chinese residents
are delivering their freedoms but the
businesses in the city of Chengdu a
return to pre-pandemic levels of
customers still a long way off
it's really really tough we can't do
business this way anymore now that
things have opened up it also means the
positive cases are all out no one comes
to the restaurant
Beijing is still adjusting too there's a
sense of cautiousness here people in the
capital getting used to the new rules
which include being able to quarantine
at home
I think everyone in Beijing is going to
be infected eventually it's only a
matter of time it has become a common
thing now if you're infected get
treatment if you're not infected just
carry on with your life
widespread protests pushed China's
government to finally let go of its zero
covert policy now having spent years
stressing the health risks of the
coronavirus authorities are trying to
reassure people this interview on
Chinese State tv pointing to the World
Health Organization for a more positive
picture
but during the last several months so we
can see the who in my opinion is growing
very optimistic about the future uh the
recent announcement from from who is
showing that we are very close to the
data that we can say covid-19 will not
be a global pandemic and a threat to the
human being
that the Swift change in policy may take
longer to become a reality as anxiety
about the coronavirus endures